what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and more major twists
have just been dropped on us in the
seventh at least send story and they
have massive implications on the story
as a whole so that is exactly what I
will be talking about in this video we
just got some very valuable information
about the relationship between Mellie
Otis and his brother celtris and we have
some major new developments in the epic
battle between Mellie Otis and a demon
king so I can't wait to carefully
examine all of it here with you Before
we jump into it a huge thank you to raid
shadow legends for sponsoring this video
I've been playing raid for several
months and the game is growing extremely
fast rage shadow legends is a brand-new
collection RPG and almost 10 million
players worldwide have already
downloaded the game within just three
months the game has great graphics
strategic gameplay huge boss fights an
amazing storyline and over 400 champions
for you to collect and personally
customized my favorite champion is El
hane she has a beautiful design and
excellent moves a huge new update is now
live and there is a new awesome reward
program for new players you can now get
a daily login reward every day for the
first 90 days in the game everyone can
find something for themselves in this
game and the option to fight other
players online is a specialty fun so
what are you waiting for go to the video
description click on the special links
and you will get 50,000 in silver and a
free epic champion as part of the new
player program to start your journey try
it out for yourself the game is totally
free on Android and iOS just click the
link in the description for a free
mobile game raid is exceptional and you
don't have to just take my word for it
with more than 200,000 reviews raid has
an almost perfect score in the Play
Store and as usual this video will
contain manga spoilers we're gonna be
talking about the latest developments in
the seven deadly sins stories so please
proceed with caution you have been
warned chapter 319 starts off with a
brief one-page flashback to an exchange
between zelgius and meliodas from a long
time ago this exchange is taking place
before meliodas fell in love with
Beth and decided to betrayed a demon
clan and that is really interesting
because we know so little about Melly
Otis's life before he met Elizabeth we
see zelgius approach meliodas and asked
brother do you have a sec cell just has
this friendly innocent look in his eyes
and meliodas turns around and looks at
him with this cold ruthless stare a
stare that reminds me of the demon Kings
eyes when he was in melioidosis body and
zelgius just says never mind it's
nothing the cold and ruthless look in
melioidosis eyes intimidate zelgius into
silence zelgius probably wanted to tell
his brother about something important in
his life such as his relationship with
gelda but when he saw how meliodas
looked at him he instantly realized that
meliodas would not care about what
zelgius had to say at this point in time
malleolus was fiercely loyal to their
father the demon king and since we know
that their father thinks all forms of
law were just a sign of weakness and
foolishness it is no wonder that zell
just decided to just keep quiet back in
the present moment Melly Otis is
recalling this brief exchange from the
past and he confirms that these types of
conversations between him and his
brother occurred countless times Melly
Otis always took this cold attitude
towards eldress because back then he was
obeying all of the demon King's orders
and he didn't have time were interested
in listening to what his brother had to
say Mele Otis now desperately wants
elders to fight back against the demon
Kings control and he wants to get the
chance to finally talk to Zell dress's
brothers and have a real heart-to-heart
with him however while notice is having
these feelings the demon king mocks him
for not using his full power to fight
because malleolus is afraid that he will
hurt his brother and demon king
confirmed that his powers are recovering
and increasing rapidly thanks to the
magic lake the demon king says that soon
he will be back to his maximum demon
king power level even in this new vessel
and then suddenly he transforms and
attains a new form his appearance
changes he becomes taller and more
muscular and he is now wearing armor
with all 10 commandments infused into
the chest plate of the armor the time of
Melly Otis dominating this fight seems
to be over because as opposed to the
situation in the last future
it is clear that the demon king has now
gotten significantly stronger Melly Otis
lands a punch right on the demon King's
face but now it has no effect and the
demon king takes control of the fight
knocking Melly Otis around with a
barrage of powerful blows Melly Otis
refuses to give up on Zell dress and he
calls out for his brother to fight back
but the demon king tells him that
zelgius is lost in sweet illusions of
gelda that the demon king has created
for him and the demon king also says
that soon zelgius will vanish completely
mani Otis retains the upper hand in the
fight by powering up further so that his
demon mark becomes visible on his
forehead and so that his eyes turned
dark like they do when he is in assault
mode but even though this allows when
the oldest to regain the upper hand for
now we have to remember that the demon
king is constantly getting stronger
thanks to the magic lake so if this
continues then pretty soon even this
powerup will not be enough to stop him
back inside of Zell juices consciousness
zelgius tells the fake gelda that he had
a dream about trying to talk to his
older brother that he looked up to so
much but he was scared to talk to him in
the end because his brother was so
intimidating Zell juices dream is of the
same exchange that meliodas was thinking
back to at the beginning of the chapter
implying that maybe Melly Otis was able
to somehow get through the Zell dress
and that is why he was remembering the
exact same moment in their past zelgius
tells gelda that he wasn't actually
scared of talking to Melly Otis but he
was scared of the demon king their
father because he would never understand
where he was coming from celtris didn't
want to only talk about killing enemies
he wanted to talk about other things as
well
casual things like what Melly Otis liked
to drink what the world outside the
demon realm is like and what kind of
girl gelda is and in that moment the
fake gelda reveals herself
the fake gelda says that that's
ridiculous and who cares about any of
that anymore something that I'm willing
to bet that the real gelda would never
say and zelgius has a moment of surprise
when he hears gelda speaking in this way
the fake gelda proceeds to tell zelgius
to sleep on her lap because he must be
tired and she Caudill's him in her a.m.
bosom zelgius appears to be falling
asleep and in the meantime on the
outside the demon Kings power continues
to rise as meliodas notices that Zelda's
presence is fading away at this rate
zelgius presence may disappear
completely giving the demon king full
and permanent control of Zelda's body
and the chapter ends on this dark note
however I believe that zelgius picked up
on the fact that the fake gelda just
said something that the real gelda would
never have said because the fake gelda
is just an illusion created by the demon
king she has the same beliefs as the
demon king and she said that selfishness
thoughts about being close to his
brother and actually talking to him
heart-to-heart about things that are not
related to killing enemies is ridiculous
and pointless but I'm willing to bet
that the real gelda
would never say this she would never
dismiss itself just as feelings in this
way and I think that this will spark
zelgius to realize that something is
wrong that something is off and he will
wake up from the illusion and start
fighting back to regain control over his
body I'm not sure whether this will
happen right in the next chapter or
whether we're going to have to be teased
for a few more chapters first but I
definitely can't see zelgius just dying
here and now zelgius will definitely
come to his senses and wake up
but then he will be faced with the
prospect of trying to fight and overcome
his father's control as his father
continues to get stronger and stronger I
have to say that even though the demon
king has now reached Sholto cur levels
when it comes to being a terrible father
I find him to be a fascinating villain
someone who is willing to manipulate his
own sons to such an extent is truly a
psychopath but that also makes him an
interesting and terrifying villain
anyone who thought that the demon king
was really about to be defeated by
malleolus and Elizabeth so easily was
sadly mistaken because as we have seen
in Chapter 319 the demon king was just
stalling for time as he continues to get
stronger while melioidosis presence in
the mortal realm continues to create
more problems this fight keeps getting
more and more complex and it's anyone's
guess how the fight will escalate in the
future I predict that the real gelda
will play some role in getting zelgius
to snap out of the illusion and I also
predict that King Arthur Pendragon will
return in some capacity and that he will
also play an important role
ultimately defeating the forces of evil
we also know that Big Daddy sunshine
also known as eScan or is about to make
his epic return in the fight against the
massive Endura that the demon king
summoned into the mortal realm so things
are definitely going to heat up even
more in the near future and I can't wait
to see how it all plays out let me know
what you guys think what will happen
next in the epic battle between the
demon king of the sins and Elizabeth and
how will the fight ultimately end also
are we ever going to see the supreme
deity make any sort of impact on the
plot of the story let me know down in
the comments I always love hearing from
you if you enjoy the seven deadly sins
content on this channel you can leave a
like to let me know and if you're new to
anime uproar please don't forget to
subscribe and hit that notification bell
don't forget to check out our awesome
sponsor raid Shadow legends link in the
description a huge thank you to all of
our anime uproar patrons for supporting
our work I want to give a special thank
you to our pro hero tier patrons
including the one and only Gilgamesh
nothing but a fan Jason Wilson and Kings
Alger's another huge thank you to our
the one tier patrons the ones who stand
above all other clans including baby ray
ace Ingrid ah al Olin Adam Adam AK and
makoto-kun and at the very pinnacle of
interdimensional greatness the tier
reserved only for Legends a massive
thank you to Regan Harrison a disciple
of Lords we go himself if you guys feel
that our content provides value for you
and you want to support more be sure to
check out our patreon link in the
description even donating a single
dollar will give you access to our anime
up for patron exclusive discord and your
name will appear in our videos along
with these amazing people as always
thank you guys so much for watching I
really appreciate it and until next time
see our space cowboys
[Music]